shots ring out from behind the wall of  the presidential palace  journalists and cameramen waiting to  enter the complex had to run for cover  confusion followed slowly it emerged  what had happened  i live in this area it was around six  o'clock when the shooting started then  there were explosions and people started  running away  president karzai's seat of office is  known as a fortress the brazen attack  comes just days after the taliban  indicated they are willing to enter  peace talks with the government and the  u.s  but they've made it clear they won't  renounce violence  the attackers reportedly came by car  armed with guns and explosives  the ensuing gun battle lasted an hour  and a half  the guards at the gate resisted  according to his official diary  president karzai was due to be at a  press conference inside the palace  shortly after the gunman attacked a  palace official has confirmed he is  unharmed